نحن الان نقف امام مجمع الشفاء المجمع
الذي يحتوي على اكبر عدد من النازحين
الجمعيه تساءل كيف تدير العائلات امورها
وتدبر قوت يومها في ظل الحصار العنيف
بالاضافه الى النقص الموارد الكبير بعمل
رز وبنبيع للناس بدهم ياكله ما فيش ما انت
شايف معاناه فيش اكل فيش شرب فيش حياه ولا
شح ايش ب نعمل لولا الرز كان الناس ميتين
من الجوع بنطبخ على النار اه على النار
على الحطب بنلم حطبات ونولع عليهم وبنشتغل
يا اخوي صحيح لانه مش ملقين غير الرز
والرز هذه اللي تكلفتها خمسه شيكل بنشتري
كل يوم ب 100 شيكل رز زيك عشان نطعم
اولادنا فش ولا ولا نص كيلو طحين كيلو
طحين وصل فوق 30 شيكل اب ابو ثلاثه شيكل
اجواء سيئه جدا جدا للغايه يعني عننا احنا
اطفال وعندي اربع اولاد معهم اولاد كل
واحد معه ست افراد فبم ياكلوا فاضطر
نستبدل اكل البيت وطبيخ البيت بالمعكرونه
بالرز
ال حتى
الخبز لانه كل ي ي للاق الطحين نعجل فطير
يعني فراشيح وحتى الولد ما بتشبع
الفرشوش بدهم ياكلوا فالوضع هذا اسوا وضع
تعرضنا له احنا في الحروب كلها يعني عشره
حروب من7 للان وهذا اسوا وضع احنا نتعرض
الجميع يزاحم في هذا المكان لسد رمق افراد
عائلته
هذه الطنجره الوحيده او الاناء الوحيد
الذي يتغذى منه ما يزيد عن 60 الف نازح
لكن ايضا الجميع يزاحم لنقل الرساله
الساميه ومعاناه الناس في هذا المكان هي
سادس مدرسه احنا نغير يعني من هلا وشر
اعينا ونروح اللي مه
قرش شرف فش مش ملاق اكل لا اولادنا ولا ش
ولا انا عندي ست اد الان الاناء هو فارغ
بلا ارز وايضا بقي الجوع يسيطر على كثير
من العائلات النازحه في هذا
المكان الدقائق المعدوده التي وقف بها هذا
الشاب امام مجمع الشفاء الطبي سدت رمق
الكثير وبقي الاكثر بلا لقيمات ليتغذى
عليها افراد عائلاتهم عائلاتهم في داخل
مجمع الشفاء الطبي من امام المجمع
اسماعيل الغول قناه
الجزيره